what we want to do today is to learn how
to attack a castle King okay when we
think about just different formations
I'm just going to put a formation up on
the board here for a second this
formation blacks King how many of you
think this is true it's pretty safe I
know I do
that's a very the pawns are a good
shield right in front of the king
the knight makes nice protection the
bishop is close and the rook is close as
well if we were going to attack blacks
King what defender should we push away
young man
the g7 pawn that would be a good one
what else what other defendant young
lady that would be great if we would
take away this pawn on g7 and this bond
on f7 that black King would start to
become a little naked what do you think
young men what other piece would we like
to remove from blacks defense do you
have
precisely precisely right what he said
was if we could eliminate this night
let's say if we could chase it away with
a a pawn and then if we were to put a
bishop over here and let's say a queen
over here notice that that knight on f6
is a vital defender to this king just as
the young man said and he said it very
well if you could get rid of that Knight
what's the checkmate in one
what's the checkmate in one young man in
the back yes well the bishop wouldn't be
checkmate in one but the Queen certainly
would I like the Queen okay so all we're
trying to do here is make an imagination
what we could try to do and eliminating
that knight on f6 in this type of a of a
castle position is a really good idea I
really also like this idea of
eliminating those two pawns because that
would really expose blacks King now
let's change it up look this is what I
call a fortress formation for black
notice how many of you think that the
black King is really safe I did I
thought that this was the safest King I
could get now imagine we could do
anything we want we're just trying to
think what would be a great attacking
set set up of all of blacks pieces and
pawns that are defending his King which
one should we try to eliminate which
ones do you think is good young man
yes we should try to get rid of this guy
that would be good that would make the
Kings defenses a little bit weak what
else what else
young lady yeah rid of that guy we
definitely want to get rid of him what
else what else what else would be good
young man that would be good because if
we could get rid of the pawn on h7
potentially who knows maybe we could set
up a checkmating eye scheme over here
okay and yes and then you have another
idea
g7 why is that ah f7 I like eliminating
that pawn as well because that would
expose blacks King okay so what we just
did is a little bit what chess players
called theory okay what do I mean by
that when you and I play together what
we're doing is we're practicing we
practice when you and I analyze together
it said you know I think I would like to
do this or you say to me no I think it's
more important that we attack over here
then we're sharing analysis together
that's called theory chess grandmasters
do both sometimes they just love to
practice and sometimes they need to
think about their formation what I'm
going to show you is a a well known
attacking scheme
okay so right now what we have is we
have the French defense this is called
the French defense okay the French
defense and white doesn't particularly
know what he's doing in the French
defense he could capture the pawn he
could push the pawn he could defend upon
defended the pond like this not bad not
bad black should capture this pond he
did not black instead chose to develop
his night that's a pretty good move
right develop a night that's pretty good
and white attacked that night just told
that night it had to move and the night
retreated the night retreated here okay
so far nothing specials happening is
just what it is
white developed his night black
developed his bishop white made an
interesting decision I don't know if it
was a very good one or not but you tell
me white played this move isn't that
crazy
so white played this move h4 that
doesn't have anything to do with the
center and what white is trying to do is
to discourage black from castling
kingside
Arjen was saying that white that black
should now make an effort to move with
his King into safety on the Queen side
notice that in this position there's a
lot of black pieces on the Queen side
blacks King might be safer over on the
on the Queen side instead black castle
okay so now we have a castle position
but what key defender is missing
remember in the first position I showed
you what key defenders missing I am the
knight on f6 remember that night that
was here when the knight was on f6 it
was defending which pawn which part
yes the knight on f6 was defending this
pawn on h7 white starts to think white
starts the thing is blacks king in
safety in safety the pawn shield is very
good but that Knight defender is missing
the knight defender is missing
maybe maybe white could take advantage
of the fact there's no defender woo I
don't want you all to answer me right
away rather I want you to think about it
white decided to play the move Bishop
takes h7 check now think about this for
a moment and I want you to ask yourself
a question that I'm going to ask you was
this a good sacrifice yes or no think
about it give yourselves 10 20 seconds
did is this would you give up your
bishop for a pawn would you give up your
now imagine that he takes if he were to
capture the bishop then how would you
continue your attack if you had the
white pieces you just gave up a bishop
how would you continue how many of you
think it's a good idea to sacrifice how
many of you think no that shouldn't work
I mean blacks king is in safety okay
well let's find out well first of all if
you move your king I could move back
with the bishop and I stole a pawns for
free so let's imagine that you take the
bishop okay
so takes the bishop okay it's White's
turn white to play young man what do you
think white should do
Queen on d1 to d2 with what idea let's
say you he runs away with his king we
didn't really make a good its King is a
little bit safety at the moment do we
have another good move yes young man
what do you think
Queen d3 check now that is very
compelling because the Queen would
attack the king and the king would be
forced to move back and there would be a
but how would you follow up let's say
that you are right that this is a very
good move and the King would go back how
could you
attack h7 again not so easy
not so easy just a second so let's go
back to this position and Queen d2 Queen
d3 our suggestions do we have another
move young man in the blue yes ah thank
you
that was the beautiful move and we're
about to understand why white played
this very mysterious move with his H
pawn correct
correct so white plays the move Knight
g5 check with the idea if the knight is
captured then the King is put in to
check by the rook and what happens if
the King goes back are you okay
Queen to h5 and now black is being
threatened with two checkmates right
queen h8 is a checkmate threat Queen h7
is a checkmate threat and what if I give
a space for Mike yes are you oh you're
very good g7 g6 and there's no way to
stop Queen h7 and Queen h8 checkmate
Bravo Bravo let's go back let's go back
for just a moment the night has come to
g5 check last time black took the night
we recaptured with a pawn discover check
and we were in trouble
hold on one other variation let's try it
this time like this last time we move
back with a king what happens if we move
up with the King think about it think
about it what's a good move for a white
young man what do you think Jack that's
pretty good
and what about the King coming here
Wow look at that King I could go pawn to
g4 check is that King and Safety by the
way okay
Honda g4 check is pretty good I was more
afraid of pawn to g6 check but this pawn
to g4 check is pretty good go ahead and
show me how you're gonna checkmate
blacks cake stalemate this knows okay
but this pawn is hanging can you guys
figure out a checkmate our young and
King takes d4 rook h3 maybe the King
would run all the way away so hold on
iron says Knight c3 check King takes d4
rook h3 how is this possible this King
went from g8 and it's running hopefully
over the green side holy cow that wasn't
good just a second you guys should be
able to checkmate faster okay
don't let that King escape don't let it
in take the pawn young man in the orange
yes Queen h7 check ok no block your
queen are you Bishop e3 whoa Bishop e3
and do you guys see what the checkmate
threat is okay oh no I wanted to play
bishop here to sit oh gosh okay
young man what do you think what's a
good move for white rook to h3 check how
many of you agree that's a good move
okay and now your anger what do you
think okay yes rook age two how many
like that move
how many think there's a better move for
white than rook H two young men in the
neck yes yes okay that's pretty good but
I thought rook a key was okay yeah
better King g2 and white to move it's
protecting it's being protected by day
oh yeah g3 checkmate did you guys see
that I'm sure you saw that whoa rook g3
checkmate also what I thought you should
have done way back here when we got to
this situation we have just sacrificed
our bishop we went check who and here
you guys play g4 I was afraid of g6
check to the King King here and now
what's a good move for white eye on
what's a good move for white queen g4
did you guys see this one is that King
and safety that at all no King safety
here okay let's do it again
from from the start here a moment there
was a bishop here so the King has just
captured the bishop we have played
Knight check
we have analyzed together you and I we
have been analyzing the ramifications of
Bishop takes g5 and we decided black
would lose if he takes the bishop
what if black were to retreat think
about your moves carefully
how would you follow up if you were
white
how would you continue your attack young
men excellent move Queen h5 now remember
that knight on f6 which was a key
defender when it was here it was
defending the square h7 now that it got
chased away the Queen is threatening to
come to h7 and a devastating mate I'm
going to move my rook young man yes yes
I could have done that yes our young
queen h7 check King f8 Queen h8
checkmate how many of saw that checkmate
do you know there was a game that was
just being played between father and son
where it was exactly this checkmate
alright let's say in this position you
have played queen h5 let's say I played
Bishop check ah are you very good
c3 and let's say I move my bishop away
so why did I give bishop check because a
moment ago Arjen showed a variation
where my queen checked the king went
here the Queen gave me checkmate because
my bishop was in the way so that's why I
moved the bishop now think about your
move carefully this is important
analysis what
do you think as White's best move young
man and yes yeah no yeah okay young man
queen h7 check King f8 Arjen ah Queen
takes f7 let's think if you had gone
check check
you would have you would have forced
blacks King to run like a rabbit and you
could have captured a pond but now black
can defend is f7 pawn okay have this
position this picture in your mind for
just a moment and we're going to go back
what are you on said was Queen takes f7
check that's the difference between the
Queen being on d3 and the Queen being on
h5 when the Queen was on d3 it only had
one possibility with the Queen on h5 it
has two this is a great move this is a
great I have no choice I have to move my
king now once again
how would you prosecute White's attack
young men what do you think yes that's a
good move I'm not sure about that one I
think he might be able to take the
knight oh I'm not sure yes what do you
think
you did that that was the last turn
yes and it's your turn that woo do you
guys see how could white check blacks
King young man how could white check
like correct Queen h5 check now I have
no choice
there's no other square I can go to then
g8 now it's your turn young man what do
you think yes Knight h7 well that
doesn't really attack we want to
prosecute the king young man in the red
yes no no no no no no in chess if you
repeat the exact same position three
times it's a draw you can't get
forfeited no no no no no way really bad
luck bad luck okay white to play Ariane
what's the right move come on
whites whites turn Queen h7 check King
comes to f8 only square and now Queen h8
check King to e7 only square and now
Queen takes g7 check mate do you see
this pattern let's go back for a moment
we were here a moment ago
and the first time when we play check we
pushed the king we play check we pushed
the King we left an F pawn on the board
the pawn on f7 remains ah not so good in
this position what we can do is first
capture the f7 pawn so now it's gone and
now the same pattern but this time is
checkmate thanks to the fact there's no
f7 fine young men a windmill kind of
thing that's exactly right okay this
sacrifice is known as the bishops
sacrifice and for hundreds of years
top champions grandmasters have been
chip mating a castle king by chasing
away the defender the knight and
sacrificing this bishop this is a very
very typical pattern let's go back for a
second
one more time we have one more look okay
so we've just sacrificed our bishop the
King is taken we've just played Knight
g5 we saw together you and I we refuted
Bishop takes g5 because of H takes g5
and we saw checkmates we've also refuted
the king retreat because of Queen h5
what if black played King h6 give it
some thought give it some thought if you
had the white pieces there's no longer
Queen h5 you can't checkmate me anymore
but what could you do what can you do
young man yes yes
that's correct you can move the knight
on g5 away and it's a discovered check
against blacks King now ah that's what I
was hoping to hear okay how many of you
think Knight takes c6 check to the King
and attacking the Queen is a good move
pretty good so do i by the way how many
of you think Knight takes f7 chat to the
king check to the King that's called a
double check and also attacking the
Queen how many think that's a good move
yeah okay which one's better the first
one is the best move or the second one's
the best move pretty pretty tough in
truth both both captures are really good
both captures are winning thanks to the
discover check like if you capture here
and I move my king and you take the
Queen that was pretty good business
that's very good business for white so
that's winning the reason I like the
second one better it's it's it's really
really close I like the second one
better because it's double check double
checks are very very very forcing checks
okay let's go back a moment now
want you to think about this position
remember how many variations we've been
analyzing this is what chess
grandmasters do they analyze one two
three maybe even four variations so far
you guys have been studying and
analyzing a lot of variations what about
this move yeah King to g6 King to h6 got
killed
how about King to g6 give it some
thought
young man what do you think about this
move Bravo
pawn to h5 check so remember of the a
moment ago this very important variation
in one case when the bishop captured the
knight this little tiny guy this little
pond recaptured and discovered check and
the rook is now a hero now this little
pond which played that vital role in
being able to support the knight and
recapture just as the young man said it
moves up the board oh my gosh well not
the first of all let's check what would
happen in case of King alive how many
think it's checkmate in one move how
many think there are two ways to
checkmate in one move how many think
there are three ways to checkmate in one
move how many thumb aney do you think
how many think this for you see one who
sees two how many saw g4 checkmate yeah
that was my favorite too how many saw
Queen f3 checkmate that was the first
one did you
that was just what was your first one
the one with the pawn okay so now we
know this - checkmate someone one with
the Queen one more the pun okay so hold
on let's do it again
h5 check now you force me here and
what's your move young man my favorite
move thank you so much
Knight takes f7 check let's say King
goes now I want you to think here I want
you to think about this should you take
the queen right away
or do you have a better move young man a
man after my heart I think you're right
but maybe maybe that Queen isn't running
maybe you have another really good move
correct correct it has to be check so
young man yes Queen C at the moment you
can take the Queen but this move is
actually stronger it attacks the King
right we'll find out for a moment in
just a moment the King comes back now is
it time to grab the Queen all those in
favor okay the eyes have it okay now
you're winning the game you have got the
game won oh you just can't wait to show
your mom how you're gonna how you won
one of the hardest things in chess is to
win a winning position in this position
how should white prosecute his attack
and then
not so sure young man what do you think
checkmate down there so the young man is
saying is he's seeing because he's a
good player he has experience and he
sees a pattern he's probably saw before
he's suggesting Queen to g3 followed by
Bishop to h6 followed by queen take g7
the pawn couldn't take the bishop
because it'd be in a pin that's a very
good idea
young man Wow are we on a roll that is a
great move huh
well it's not even a sacrifice remember
when I set up those King position
positions and I said to you what were
the pieces or the pawns you wanted to
eliminate somebody said to me
the g7 Punk and I agreed and somebody
said the f7 punt and I agreed and
somebody said the knight on f6 think
about this a moment you've eliminated
the pawn on f7 the knight on f6 has been
pushed away the pawn on h7 got captured
the one remaining guy that's sheltering
blacks King is the pawn on g7 I'd love
to get rid of it
yeah I would too okay so think about it
for a second after the capture can white
make a checkmate in two moves think it's
going to be a yes or no question
so I'm gonna ask you to raise your hand
to all of those who say yes in two moves
all of those who think no way blacks
King is safe you can't checkmate in two
moves okay for those of you who thought
that there was checkmate in two moves
what is the first move for white young
man what's the first move
that's a good boy I like that but you
can start with a check start with a
check young man that's a very very good
check I like that check very much
there's a stronger check with the queen
though there's a stronger check yes unit
right queen g6 check okay what if I go
King f8 now your tip is that checkmate
yes it is and that would be there the
second move what about hold your horses
what about King h8 his Bishop takes h6
the best move now young man in the blue
yes correct
checkmate so checkmate in two all right
let's go back just one you're beginning
to get the idea of how important it is
to eliminate this pawn let me ask you
one more question instead of capturing
this pawn which we just saw let's say
pawn goes here now what would you do if
you were white young man in the blue
pawn to h7 and then the King would be
forced to block does white have a better
move than pawn to h7
young man yes Bravo Queen the g6 if I go
here is that checkmate is that checkmate
yeah okay so your your guys to play what
about King here young man that looks
pretty good so now you're threatening to
get a queen let's say I play blocked
with the bishop I could take with a pawn
let's say you make a mistake and maybe
it's not such a bad move let's say you
make a queen and I take now think about
this position and that's a sure okay
rook takes 8 a check that's move number
one I have to move my King here now it's
your turn
our young Queen age 7 at 2 times what we
just did is we were thinking about how
would we attack our opponent if he
castle on the King side the next time
we'll get together we'll figure out how
to checkmate an opponent who's castling
on the Queen side all right you guys
have a good weekend thank you for coming